il y a un an presque jour pour jour les
premières voitures du rem fraîchement
débarqué de l'inde était dévoilé en
grande pompe ça a été fabriqué par des
gens qui ont une grande habitude faire
ceci mais au fil des tests effectués à
brossard et surtout au fil des
inspections des vagues ont reçu la
caisse de dépôt responsable du projet a
vite déchanté des barres d'appui pour
les passagers mal soudés des fils
électriques mal protégé des marques
laissées après le mauvais ajustement
d'une porte les problèmes de finition
sont nombreux dans cette lettre adressée
au constructeur alston par le patron de
cdpq infra jean marc carbo on peut lire
que les défauts constatés pourrait
engager la qualité du service qui sera
offert aux passagers du rem en termes de
fiabilité de confort de qualité et dans
certains cas présenter un risque
potentiel de blessures aux passagers il
n'y a pas de panique en ce moment
contraire les choses avancent bien mais
de notre côté on le voit par cette
lettre on a une volonté d'être
extrêmement rigoureux dans la qualité du
produit final le constructeur alstom
assure que c'est lui qui va payer pour
toutes les réparations à faire et ajoute
qu'un plan d'action détaillé a été mise
en place depuis la réception de cette
lettre pour améliorer la situation
ce que la caisse de dépôt confirme
sur le coup et les champs c'est avec ce
qu'on passe vraiment dans la finition
mais cette histoire donne des munitions
à ceux qui auraient voulu que les 212
voiture du projet soient fabriqués au
québec plutôt qu'à l' usine d'alstom de
ce tri city en inde où les ouvriers
gagnent 2 dollars de l'heure françois
legault jette la pierre à l'ancien
gouvernement libéral je l'avais dit
quand j'étais dans l'opposition
je l'avais dit haut et fort sa pas de
bon sens qui ait aucune condition
contenu québécois dans la commande du
rêve j'espère qu'on va tenir compte de
ces c'est ce dérapage l'os pour pouvoir
donner les contours qui est de la tombe
et le québec est un peu se tenir compte
de l'expertisé travail aux québécois la
caisse de dépôt ne s'engage pas à
construire au québec la deuxième phase
du projet m de l'est elle précise
toutefois qu'elle aura la volonté de
maximiser le contenu local tout en
respectant les accords internationaux
ici jean sébastien cloutier radio canada
brossard